When amoviebecomes an overnight hit, or
a box office bomb, it's often thecastthat
gets the credit or blame. But audiences might
never ask how different things could have
been if other actors or actresses werecast-
or how close their favoritemoviescame
to being something completely different. Here
are Screen Rant's 10AmazingMovieCastingsThat
Almost Happened.
Face/Off
The story that sawmoviestars Nicolas Cage
and John Travolta swap faces is famous for
its cheesy performances, but as fun as it
was, it could have been truly incredible.
The script was actually written for Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Sylvester Stallone, both
at the top of their game at the time. Other
duos like Bruce Willis and Alec Baldwin were
considered, but Michael Douglas and Harrison
Ford seemed the most likely. When director
John Woo decided on the leading men instead,
Douglas remained as a producer.
Finding Nemo
Even Pixar makes mistakes, since they finished
the entire undersea adventure with actor William
H Macy voicing the role of Nero's dad, Marlon.
The actor is no slouch, but when Disney's
CEO saw the finished version, he famously
said themoviewas nowhere near as good
as the studio believed. They soon recruited
actor Albert Brooks to revoice the entiremovie,
and his energetic delivery made it Pixar's
biggest hit to date.
The Matrix
It's impossible to imagine anyone other than
Keanu Reeves as the hero of this trilogy,
but there was a time when another soft-spoken,
enigmatic actor was offered the part of The
One: Nicolas Cage. The Hollywood veteran turned
down the part since it would be filmed far
from home in Australia, leavingmoviefans
to wonder how completely different the series
- and the actors' careers - could have turned
out.
Who Framed Roger Rabbit?
It's hard to think that this mix of cartoon
and live action could have been better, but
Steven Spielberg and Robert Zemeckis' first
choice for the grouchy detective Eddie Valiant
was apparently Harrison Ford. When he proved
too expensive, they turned to their second
choice: comedy legend Bill Murray. Since Murray
has no agent, only a voicemail for offering
roles, he didn't get the message. The worst
part? Murray later admitted that if he'd known
of the offer, he would've taken it in second.
Super Mario Bros.
The video gamemovieproved to be a but
of a joke in Hollywood, with star Bob Hoskins
forever calling the part of Mario Mario his
biggest regret. But would you believe an even
bigger name actually pursued the role? Tom
Hanks even got himself attached to star as
the mustachioed plumber, before the studiocastHoskins
instead, believing he was the more bankable
actor. We'll let time be the judge on that
one.
The Bourne Identity
He was an unlikely hero, but Jason Bourne
completely redefined the modernmoviespy,
and made Matt Damon a household name overnight.
The part was originally going to be played
by Brad Pitt, who decided that another Spy
thriller, Spy Game, was a better choice. It's
hard to argue Pitt would've ruined the series,
but with a fifth instalment in the franchise
coming to theatres, it was probably for the
best.
Pulp Fiction
Quentin Tarantino's breakout film was like
a Hollywood game of musical chairs, with Bruce
Willis making it clear he wanted the lead
role of Vincent Vega. John Travolta ended
up beating him out, along with Oscar winner
Daniel Day Lewis - Rumored to be the only
role Lewis ever actively campaigned for. The
director still liked Willis for the boxer
Butch, but had promised the part to Matt Dillon.
When Dillon said he needed a night to consider
the offer, TarantinocastWillis instantly,
saying that if he didn't want the part after
reading the script, the director didn't want
him either.
The Avengers
The Incredible Hulk's big screen history hadn't
been easy, with THREE actors playing the part
in less than a decade. But that almost wasn't
the case. When talks with Ed Norton reprising
his role in The Avengers fell through, director
Joss Whedon prepared a list of replacements.
Mark Ruffalo was his top pick, knowing it
might be an unpopular choice with the studio.
They surprised him, by admitting he was at
the top of theirs, after they had tried tocasthim
in the previous solomovie, making the change
to the shared universe... not a change at
all, really.
Inglorious Basterds
Quentin Tarantino hit a home run with his
World War 2 story, but the original plannedcastwould
have felt completely different. It was the
German actor Christoph Waltz who brought the
villain Hans Landa to life, but Tarantino
originally planned tocastLeonardo DiCaprio
as the Nazi officer. He alsocastcomedian
Adam Sandler as Donny Donowitz, a.ka. The
Bear Jewish, who dropped out. Tarantino turned
to his friend Eli Roth, and finally got tocastDiCaprio
as the villain in Django Unchained years later.
Batman Begins
It's never easy tocastthe Batman on film,
but director Christopher Nolan managed to
gather some serious talent - and didn't let
them escape once he passed them over for the
part. Irish actor Cillian Murphy was a serious
frontrunner for the new Bruce Wayne, along
with Aussie Heath Ledger. Christian Bale won
the part, but the competition clearly made
an impression: Nolancastthem as the villains
of the first two films, as the Scarecrow and
Joker, respectively.
Those are some the craziestcastingclose
calls, we know of, but which ones are your
favourites? Let us know in the comments, and
remember to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one!